all right so my name is Sonia Kagura I
have been doing application security for
coming up on like 10 years I started and
actually funny thing I'm still with the
same company like that does not happen
in this world and age we've been
acquired but I was still working with
the same people
so I started its application security
consultant as an intern actually and
then after being in consulting for about
six seven years
I switched more into research and now
I'm senior research engineer at synopsis
I'm also doing my PhD at George
Washington University and this work is
actually part of my academic research so
not not directly linked to my work
but I've been doing research in
JavaScript security for like five years
so it's still that area and except for
working I also love doing bottom dancing
I love diving and I have a daughter and
I tweet security stuff on Twitter I'm so
feel free to follow alright so why did I
choose JavaScript except for doing
JavaScript research for over six five
years if you look at the October's
report that github releases every year
from 2014 javascript has been the most
popular language and if we used to think
that javascript is only in the browser's
well of course not anymore now it's
running on servers everywhere basically
so an IOT and mobile devices etc so what
is the state of JavaScript frameworks
and usually when we talk about
frameworks people usually start thinking
about the client-side frameworks I'll
talk about the server-side frameworks as
well but I love this quote and if you
notice this was from 2012 that's a long
time ago has anything changed not really
in that era I mean there are a lot of
frameworks right when we talk about
developing JavaScript
vacations nobody writes vanilla
JavaScript code anymore it's all gonna
be frameworks and currently well I think
this data maybe is about ten months old
but in client-side JavaScript they're
about 50 frameworks as reported by a GS
report if you look at the server-side
JavaScript they're about four different
works there are full stack frameworks
that allow you to write code in
JavaScript both client-side and
server-side kind of seamlessly such as
meteor or noelia
they're not as popular I would say I
haven't seen a lot of real production
big applications using this frameworks
but that's definitely in kind of
interesting area there is a framework
for developing desk of desktop
applications now with JavaScript
electron and if you're using slack or
obvious visual code studio or whatsapp
guess what it's written in it's all
written in electron the desktop versions
and then there is JavaScript in mobile
applications for any looks like PhoneGap
and Cordova
so what is there in the frameworks for
security when developers choose a
framework how do they choose a framework
well they'll first look at the features
doesn't do what I need to do right is it
a good framework for developing single
page applications or an API or your
mobile front-end they look at is it easy
to prototype of course the best ones you
just say you know run app blah and there
you have the full backbones of the
application and you can start filling it
in and did a lot of work for you for
prototyping you look at performance is
it quick doesn't do what you know will
it scale the developers look at security
oh the fluid [ __ ] will it's with this
way do we choose the framework based on
security I'm not really like very very
rarely we consider that or at least we
know locals okay how many issues are
open
github for this framework well less than
a hundred probably okay right how many
have them been resolved good enough
right the other thing that developers
often look at is community like that's
against think I haven't mentioned here
but is there enough documentation right
is it a popular framework as everybody
else using it if I have a problem will I
go out and find an answer if I find a
security vulnerability will it will it
be fixed right how how well is it
maintained that's why these frameworks
supported by big companies like Google
and Facebook right they they do gain
traction like angular and react so in
application security when we talk about
shifting left shifting security left we
talk about finding the vulnerabilities
earlier in the development lifecycle
finding and fixing vulnerabilities right
at the design level etc and I was
thinking well if we're really thinking
shifting left can we prevent them
because that would be to the left most
right of the Sevilla development
lifecycle is preventing the
vulnerabilities versus finding and
fixing them so with that I came with a
couple questions right well framework
and frameworks help us with that can
frameworks make our applications more
secure so pose the questions does the
security of a framework help to make
application secure and does building
security controls into the framework
help make applications secure because
when we talk about secure a framework
like one part is the framework itself
doesn't have any bugs and the second
part does the framework provide security
controls that I can implement in my
application easily quickly out of the
box and the location of the security
mitigation or security can kind of using
this terms interchangeably vulnerability
mitigation and security control because
usually if you fix or prevent
vulnerability you're using some sort of
security control
so does the location of that mitigation
matter and my former collagen Steven
came up with this structure this
categorization where a mitigation can be
placed in different places and different
parts of the applications if we look at
the app so we have the framework and
then on top of it I mean we have like
os-level code first then the framework
and then the code that developers wrote
and then of course you're using
different third-party libraries on the
way so a mitigation can be placed well
level zero because this is academic
research level zero is no mitigation at
all this is our baseline application is
vulnerable level one is a custom
function something developer wrote level
two is external library something
developer pulled and starts using is it
sanitizer as a access control part right
as a C surf protection like any kind of
security control level three is a
framework plugin I know when I show you
examples you understand how that they're
very very similar but a little bit
different and then level four is a
mitigation control built into the
framework itself out of the box so if we
look at examples develop a written
function obviously know so have some
simple code here from an open source
application that I was reviewing and
here's a custom developer function which
is trying to create cross-origin
resource sharing policies across our say
we add cross-origin resource sharing
headers to the application does this
code look secure the one in the box
anybody with JavaScript experience no
why not easily reversed but I'm it's I
mean it's open source it's gonna be
there so kind of what you don't need to
reverse it's there yep yeah allow origin
is said to weld card so depending on
application functionality if it's
serving publicly available data then
it's fine but it is some if it is some
sort of private data user logged in and
now we're talking about the
users private information account
information than any application can
make a call to this application and
regardless of the origin of the request
the application will respond so the
point is developers make mistakes
haha and of course you cannot have a
slide deck without as an xkcd comic
right so that's why when developers
write crypto bad things happen so that's
I mean that's common right like we say
that if it's developer developed the
security control probably somebody
developed that control before probably
there is a third-party app library or
something that you don't need to write
your own crypto write your own
authentication like all of these things
so the second level an external library
an example would be isapi anybody
remember our wasp isapi here yeah it
died so it was it was a great idea right
it was a library that had a bunch of
security controls it had sanitization
functions authentication authorization
but it sort of didn't take off and parts
of it were implemented very well the
problem with this app it was that it was
it was originally written in Java and
for Java applications I think there were
versions for other languages later but
for Java that library wouldn't work
smoothly if you use the framework so if
you could used struts for example and
then you try to pull in asabi or you
used spring and then you try to point a
sappy it was a pain to implement both of
them there was a similar project sister
of guard I think that had kind of
similar problems and that similar
project was a female for Caesar but it
was a wasp library that implementing
with a different frame was a pain so
then the third level and that's how the
plugin for a framework is different it's
against third-party library but it is
written for a specific framework and
then it kind of works out of the box
smoothly and the JavaScript ecosystem
there are tons of
these examples so they're especially I'm
talking about the server-side know GS
JavaScript so if we look at Express
framework if we look at happy GS
framework if we look at sales there are
a ton of third-party plugins written for
these frameworks that are super easy to
pull into your application and kind of
make them work with a framework and then
an example the fourth one is when the
mitigation is built into the security
into the framework itself one example is
spring security framework that kind of
has a lot of security features for you
already built into it you don't need to
pull in a third-party library so my
hypothesis for this research was that
well if the security controls are
implemented in the framework probably
the applications are going to be more
secure so the closer we move down those
four levels to the framework itself the
applications should be better and of
course in academic world like well you
have to prove it with data kind of make
sense so my first case that it was for
cross-site scripting and everybody is
familiar with cross-site scripting how
we can mitigate that I'm not gonna kind
of go into details with this audience
but basically what I needed to do is
find open source applications using
github of course I wish I had access to
private code but not that's not
realistic to find applications that are
likely to have cross-site scripting not
every application is likely to have
cross-site scripting and like cross this
question that will be impactful so to
find these applications I was thinking
when will cross-site scripting happen it
will happen when you allow users to put
HTML markup into the application so that
should be functionality of the app that
you would allow users to use HTML markup
and types of applications like that
would be blows right when you allow
users to write their own blog posts
content management systems marketing
emails for example so any places where
you want to users allow using you know
fonts and graphics and what other like
which formatting tax things and when we
need to implement that basically we need
to render raw HTML to make these magic
things happen how to do it safely
well you to allow users to only use the
safe subset of HTML so they cannot
insert malicious scripts straight
forward and that can be done by
sanitizing you know white listing black
listing or it can be done by using a
another language like markup that again
basically only allows a safe subset of
HTML alright so we collected data from
github with the following criteria right
so we're looking for applications that
are a blog or a content management
system will at this point I was
interested in the full stack JavaScript
so that was kind of one of the criterias
and because that was 2016 with that on
this research started the front and was
there were three major frameworks
well technically template engines that
were written for use for the front end
was EGS Jade later renamed as pug and
angularjs so those were the three
frameworks I'm gonna call them
frameworks here and that we looked at
and I also wanted to make sure that the
applications are not super old so I make
sure you know they're left commit was no
later than three years ago at that time
had at least one star I would also look
at Forks so it's like somewhat popular
project and the language is gels from
HTML CSS like as long as it had
JavaScript code so we ended up with 170
applications roughly a third in each
category
and so let's look at the framework so
template engines that they used and how
they handle they raw HTML that we want
to output as users so all of them by
default escape HTML so for example in
Jade POG if you're using if you're
outputting with
you know using the equal sign or using
the curly braces it will by default do
output encoding we're safe but if we
want to output that raw HTML allowing
users to use you know different fonts
and pictures etc we would use the
interpolation so I would say you know
not equals or not curly braces similar
with eg s it had a way to interpolate
HTML so those those would be the things
that we're looking for in the code right
where we are outputting unanswered
unsanitized data and both EGS and plug
didn't have any way to have a safe
subset when they're doing the
interpolation so whatever HTML you send
them if it's like not equals to
something they're gonna output it as is
which means if somebody sends in
JavaScript expect it's gonna be output
as is and it's that code will be
vulnerable if we look at angularjs again
that's 2016 so that was I knew at the
time it does also have contextual aware
escaping by default it also allows you
to interpolate so output HTML in RAW
format but if you're using it again the
default interpolation using the ng bind
HTML directive it will actually do
sanitization by default so it will only
allow you the safe HTML subset and not
allow scripts and events like on error
onmouseover and if you really want to
output the raw raw HTML then you would
use the function trust as HTML full-on
around the data and then add it to the
ng bayan HTML they newer versions of
angular still have that functionality
they renamed the function it's now
called bypass security trust HTML or
trust URL whatever that context is so
those were the things that we would be
looking for in the applications on the
pipeline basically we had kind of
different stages so collect data from
github get those templates
the applications then for the three
different template engines we use
different parsers and then the rules to
find those vulnerable locations all of
them are based on open source since
again this is academic work
so for paga use the Pug lexer and parser
and extended those libraries for EGS I
use the the core EGS project extended
from that and edit the custom analyzer
to it and then for angular I just used
yes Linton Road custom rules for it so
scan the code then do the manual
analysis manual review of the results
because none of these tools have data
flow analysis so even if they identify a
place where raw HTML is displayed not
necessarily that raw HTML will have
malicious data tainted data right
because if it's not coming from a user
if it's coming from a hard coded you
know file that you control as a
developer it doesn't have vulnerability
so definitely when I make sure we're not
reporting something that's not a
vulnerability and then we perform
statistical analysis of the results so
what did we find
with the gdgs and angular so and again
remember that the protection levels
because Jade and POG didn't have any
built-in sanitization the only way to
have the sanitization did not talk about
it is to use mitigations of level 1 or
level 2 is you know custom write your
own custom scientist Asian function or
use a third party code basically saying
okay it's a blog post this data is
coming from a user of the blog who's
posting something I'm gonna run it
through my own custom scientist Asian
function and then I'm gonna output that
raw HTML that has been sanitized already
so that was the only way to make it
safely in those two frameworks so that's
why I put them into mitigation levels
one and two and then angular had
something out of the box so this is
level 4 and so we found that for G 8 and
age is 38 percent of the applications
for Jade and 43% of the
vacations for EGS were vulnerable versus
only 12% for angular so that kind of
proves our hypothesis right angular has
something built in applications seem to
be more secure all right again in
academia which is different from the
industry sometimes so my adviser said
well maybe the angularjs developers are
just smarter like they just write better
code how do you know how do you know
it's because of the framework right so I
had to think is like okay what can be
other factors that could potentially
influence that data and of course I
didn't talk directly with developers
github open source projects so I had to
collect some proxies for the developer
experience and knowledge and what we did
is we took the overall number of
projects created by the developer and
again by developer I mean github account
right it's usually one person but who
knows right we have to make some
assumptions here so overall number of
projects created by the developer
overall number of projects created in
JavaScript specific way so maybe their
experience in general basis the one
javascript project and all of the other
one are in c-sharp by project size
project popularity the stars the github
stars and project reuse the fork so kind
of showing how mature the application is
and then we ran the statistical analysis
they anova tests that showed that
basically once you kind of plug the data
and make the magic statistical magic
happen and get the result which is this
call this p-value that if it is less
than point zero five that means that
factor actually influences your results
and when we run the analysis we got that
the only factor that actually influenced
the result and had the correlation was
the template engine so success right
sorry bought this is proved works
awesome so the choice of the template
engine matters okay but that's only for
cross-site scripting so then I decided
to look at other vulnerabilities other
frameworks
other types of code so for the second
case study I chose cross-site request
forgery as a vulnerability because I
also wanted to look at the server-side
JavaScript frameworks and if we talk
about cross-site request forgery the
server-side is kind of more impact more
involved in fixing the vulnerability
that's where you're gonna be fixing the
variability so who knows what is the
surface alright so some people what for
those who are not super familiar it's an
attack according to last right where a
user is tricked into executing an action
when the user is logged in into the
website and is tricked by a malicious
site and executing this action that the
user didn't intend to so in this case
the user is logged in to the website in
the same browser the user goes to the
evil.com website and the evil.com
website sends a request to the target
website and the because it's coming from
the same browser the browser
automatically attaches the user session
and then the target website doesn't know
if that request came what was kind of
originated by the user or legitimately
or it was originated by the evil.com
site that's opened in the user browser
right so we don't know the common
protections the most common one is the
sister of tokens in this case the target
application first sends the token to the
user which is not a cookie and then when
the user sends a request back this token
is attached to the request so then the
target application can say oh yes I did
send you this token it matches that came
from the user where if the request comes
from the evil com
it doesn't have a way to get that cookie
from the browser so the requester that
comes without that token or you know
with whatever attacker came up with so
if the token is long enough and
cryptographically secure they cannot
Forge that token and the request is not
executed
and this can be done in post parameters
there is a way to do through double
submit cookie I'm not gonna go into the
details you can read on the OWASP
website for more about it another way to
protect from it is a two-factor
authentication
you've seen all in your like banking
applications right if it's sensitive
enough data if it's sensitive enough
transaction if you're sending money from
one location to another maybe they're
gonna ask you to you know with sent you
authentication code to your mobile
device or you have like an Aussie app or
whatever there are also ways to protect
it on the client side so one concept is
the same side cookies that is becoming
more and more popular not all browsers
support it yet but basically I think one
thing I haven't mentioned is this attack
is only possible when you are using
cookies as a session management
mechanism right if we're not using
cookies this attack cannot happen
because that's the whole call the whole
point is that when the browser sends a
request it attaches the cookies
automatically it doesn't check anything
if that session information is sent not
that all the cookies but through an HTTP
header for example the HTTP headers are
not attached automatically the cookies
are at fault here so if we could have
some sort of flag that says only attach
these cookies if the request is
originated from that same sites like if
I am on bank comm and the request is
coming from my bank account page open in
my browser to the bank comm server
attach the cookies but if I have you
know funny cats calm
open in the same browser and now funny
kids calm since their same request to
bank comm the browser says like oh wait
a second the origin is different I'm not
gonna attach this cookie because it's
marked as the same site cooking as I
said this is not yet supported by all
the browsers and then in academia there
were other solutions proposed such as
white listing expected origins like if I
am the target website I say
I do expect requests from these other
websites but not from evil comm or allow
the further referral list so kind of
similar idea like if they refer equals
this then allow the request or not but
the refers can be easily spoofed if you
have proxies in between they're going to
be removed etc etc that's why those were
just academic proposals so for this work
again I need it set of applications open
source that are likely to have
cross-site request forgery vulnerability
not every application will because what
it needs for that is there must be a
login right so the user there should be
some functionality that is only
available to the user who is logged in
who has that session and also there
should be some sensitive functionality
right if I'm just logging in and viewing
some information and then I'm you know I
have my target website open and then I'm
going to the evil calm and evil calm
also sends a request to view the
information that the get requests right
then the response is going to come to my
browser it's not going to go back to the
evil calm so see Cerf only works if
something changes on the target server
if it changes the state of the user
account or data right so I need
something that changes the state and
custom common attacks common like
functionality that is attacked is so you
have user profile like changing an email
address and you user profile why is that
sensitive why that is that like super
bad
so you can get a notifications to to
somebody else okay what else forget
password right somebody goes in says I
think that password send me a new
password to a different email and now
they can have your account because
oftentimes people when people talk about
C surf they talk about oh you know
transferring money to a different
account come on
it's 2020 all banks have figured that
out that does not happen there is like
multi you will have your second layer of
Education you will have sis or tokens
transfer money is not a good example
anymore but yeah but things like posting
something from your account onto you
know Twitter whatever Facebook something
that you didn't want to post especially
if you are some you know political
figure celebrity whatever like that kind
of compromise as well alright so what
types of application will be vulnerable
to that so thank you okay logs if
somebody posts something from your
account that you don't want to contact
management system kind of similar it's
if it's an e-commerce if somebody buys
something using your account that's kind
of sensitive and then just kind of
generic REST API so in this case I
looked at the server-side JavaScript
applications and again so then it was
2018 the most common frameworks were
Express KOA Kauai is right now even well
I don't know if it's more popular than
Express but it's definitely like picking
up steam happy sales and Michio was kind
of interesting I'll talk about that in
detail so my goal was to have about ten
applications per framework so come back
alright so this is what we got I got
about a hundred four Express Cohen sales
and then happy it turned out not to be
as popular on github so I was only able
to find 48 total applications and kind
of you can see in different categories
right I looked for walls and CMS and
e-commerce and that's actually when I
added the REST API categories because I
just couldn't find any you know that
many CMS is developed and happy or that
ecommerce applications developed and
happy and like okay well there are some
rest it cuz happy is kind of target for
us API so I was able to find ten because
again I remember I didn't want to any
project right I wanted a project that
had some stars that has been contributed
to recently so it's kind of a little bit
real it's a total of three hundred and
sixty-four applications if we look at
how these project how these frameworks
implement the CSRF protection and again
I didn't choose the frameworks because
they had different ways of implementing
CSRF I just wanted to look at the what's
most popular right what developers are
using so it turned out that Express Khoa
and happy all had the what's called the
level three mitigation so they had
plugins for the frameworks to fix this
or F so for example Express and cocoa o
is based on it's kind of forked off of
Express that's why they're very similar
basically all you do is you add a plugin
you say you know require C Center for
required Co CSRF and then you add it to
the application you can configure it but
then you kind of add it to application
and that's all so it's super easy to use
two lines of code maybe three lines of
code if you're adding configuration so
it's you know should be pretty easy for
developers then if we look at happy also
very similar you require a plugin and
you just kind of plug it in into the
main application it slightly different
format but it's again very
straightforward sales is a configuration
driven framework so and it also kind of
claims to be pretty secure framework so
it has a lot of things built into it and
it actually had one of the features was
the seizure of protection built into
sales so that's why it's level four and
you would go into the configuration file
and you just either say sis or F equals
true or you can go into more details and
say okay I want to use the surf on Ajax
requests I want to have a specific
origin kind of more detailed
configuration and then meteor was a
special case and
mentioned before meaty or is full-stack
framework so servers developed in
JavaScript client development javascript
is pretty fantastic because you're kind
of you're developing the application
both server-side and client-side in the
same ide just like this folder is client
this folder server it's interesting
because they let the this is the
boundary of client and server washes
away really quickly and if it's the same
person and so which means the trust
washes away really quickly that's kind
of a side note but a lot of issues with
mutual applications that I've seen
developers will include business logic
into the client that actually should
belong on the server and shouldn't be in
the client because you just kind of
don't feel like those are two different
things the way the client and server
interacts in meteor is they are using
their dddp the distributed data protocol
and that protocol runs on the web
through a web socket on the ssl level so
basically one the first the client
connects to the server makes HTTP
request it first and then it establishes
a WebSocket connection and then it kind
of drops the HTTP goes down to the TLS
level and the whole communication
happens in the TLS what does that mean
for Caesar there are no cookies
so the first connection is important and
there are attacks that allow you to
hijack that but that's kind of a
different group of attacks but because
there is no cookie there is no way for
another website opened in the same
browser to send the request to the
server and pretend that it's coming from
the legitimate source because you cannot
hijack like suddenly just jump on that
WebSocket connection and start sending
your data through this that web socket
that has been already established of
course we assume that's all done over
SSL so web sock the secure WebSockets so
basically if applications developed with
by meat or it's
cannot be vulnerable to see a seraph out
of the box and then another caveat is
JSON web tokens tokens so I think there
are like three talks about jobs in this
conference super popular and when Laxmi
was talking about them yesterday she
mentioned for example that they are bad
like one of the drawbacks is that you
cannot time out you cannot invalidate
that token right well they also come
with some benefits because a jar is sent
as an HTTP header again there are no
cookies if you are using it for session
management there is no cookie which
means the server is not possible if you
are using jars so there are always
trade-offs as Alex temas was talking
about right but basically I also had to
look at those applications from github
are they using jaws because of their and
if they are then they're not vulnerable
and as we talked about meteor because
the mitigation is very different right
it's sort of for Caesar if it's sort of
built into the framework but it's
basically impossible to turn off it's
impossible to do C surf because
communication happens at a different
level so I had to modify my
categorization on these levels and add
the level 5 the architecture and level
mitigation control where the mitigation
control is not just built into the
framework but it's kind of built into
the foundation of the framework or the
platform's such that the vulnerability
just cannot happen so this is kind of
the best the best way right the on the
framework design or platform level
mitigation and I'll give you later some
examples that this is not just done once
like it has happened in the history of
software development before so again
same hypothesis does it work for Caesar
all right again similar pipeline in this
case I had to write rules I used a
eslint for all of the different
frameworks
and I had to write rules with just
different plugins that I use and for
sales configuration but they're kind of
the rest was the same so when we look at
the results they look very different
so for koa express and happy all have
mitigation at levels 3 which is a plugin
they had 14 19 percent and then 35
percent for happy kind of high and then
sales that had a framework level
mitigation level for it actually had
only 14 percent of projects that were
protected so same as the level 3 and the
interesting thing about happy was that
actually none of the applications out of
the 48 applications that I looked at
none of them had any Caesar protection
at all the reason why 35 percent or 17
of them were fixed were were not
vulnerable is because 17 of them used JW
T's so it's kind of like oh these
developers got the protection for free
they didn't even know they got it they
probably didn't even know what's the
surface funny
there was one project yeah so if you
look at koa there was one pursuit you
see that six of them were protected with
C surf and then 14 were protected with
GWT but the total number of protected
applications is 19 like kind of math
doesn't add up
so one application had actually both it
used jobs for session management but it
also used AC surf plug-in to protect
from C surf which tells me that
developer didn't realize that if you're
using judge see surf can not be possible
so that's separate
but in any case that means that my
hypothesis does not prove or see surf
right this way
we ran the statistical analysis just
making sure if there are any other
factors affecting this data and sure
enough we saw that no everything is
equal they're not a different parameter
that says Oh
the you know the sales developers are
just worse than the expressed developers
are happy developers are not just
happier but also better there's kind of
equal so yeah the hypothesis did not
prove except for applications written in
meteor because like alright well you
cannot even have that vulnerability
there so question is why right so if we
compare cross-site scripting results
with cross-site request forgery results
we can see that in cross-site scripting
there is a strong correlation that if
the protection is closer to the
framework applications are more secure
in sister that's not the case and I
started looking at the level for
protection it turns out in angularjs
that feature was enabled by default
where in sales who also have the
framework level mitigation the sister of
it occasionally by default by default
the sister flag in the configuration was
set to false so developers had to and
like that's all it takes just go and
change false to true you didn't need to
do anything else
but most people didn't do it which says
defaults are kind of important so what
can we get from this presentation what
hey what kind of work from these results
well one thing is well ideally would
choose the framework that has security
features built-in when we're starting
developing an application and then if it
has security third-party plugins or
configurations if they're not enabled by
default can we make sure is an
organization that these secure features
are used by the developers right can we
write linting rules secure coding
guidelines have you know code reviews
but will ensure that that CSRF flag is
actually set to true I mean how how hard
is that right you can't have a linter
that's sitting into your devops pipeline
and just checks that especially for
those configuration driven frameworks
and the bigger message to the
implementers of the frameworks the
builders of the frameworks like well
kinda able the security defaults that's
if it's possible oftentimes it's not
plausible because like one example for
cookies and the secure flag for the
cookies right we'll talk about who
should be only insecure and some
frameworks have the HTTP only enabled by
default because usually it doesn't break
anything but you cannot have secure flag
for the cookie enabled by default
because your prototype is probably not
gonna run on HTTPS right you're gonna
run on HTTP a so it's there there are
other dependencies to make that feature
work and then so the security folds are
important and then the last message is
that if possible if you are a framework
maintainer try to eliminate the
vulnerability by changing the
architecture of your framework somehow
if if possible right ideally so that
this vulnerability just doesn't exist
and as I said like it may sound very
wishy-washy like Oh an ideal world we
just built a framework so that there's
no vulnerabilities however do we have
buffer overflows and Java applications
no because memory management in Java was
like in the JVM was done so that buffer
overflows are not possible so that's
exactly the example of that fifth level
of mitigation another example is the the
ASLR the memory randomization right but
again kind of invalidated the ability to
do to just dump the memory and steal
information from there so this solutions
do exist in the industry they're not
easy but every now and then we're able
to completely eliminate a class of
vulnerabilities by a change in the
framework platform os-level so that
would be great if we had more of those
and with that we have a couple minutes
for questions
[Applause]
I know it's lunch time feel free to go
hi what do you consider under a level 5
architecture how the application is
deployed let's say if the application is
behind the wofe for instance what if the
graph at some point gets turned off or
you migrate the application that's why I
mean it's a different it's like all of
these protections are built into the
application the wife is something that's
outside of the application so I feel
like it's a completely different class
yeah laughs I asked kind of you name it
it's not in the application it's not I'm
not saying it's good or bad but it's
completely different
do you have any hypothesis as to why
there are such different results between
cross-site scripting and cross-site
request forgery like the level of like
security training people have or
defaults I mean cross-site scripting is
definitely more popular and that's why
it has been built into angular right
like if I asked show of hands who knows
what XSS is yeah I ever been to then
arise the hand where CEO serif is not
one thing I didn't mention like why I
chose serif is if you look at a wasp
top 10 cross-site scripting was always
in the top 3 I think last time it like
this like top 4 or 5 but kind of lowered
a little bit but it was always like this
since 2003 it's always up there CSRF in
the last one in the 2017 it's not in
there what's top 10 like it's gone in
some languages and some applications and
the reason why it's gone for example
dotnet and a lot of Java frameworks have
it built by default like it's something
that you don't need to know the
application logic to fix it you can just
say hey on every post requests require
the token even on every get requests
require the token so that's why I was
hoping to get good results that's why I
chose it
but no I didn't yeah so old-world learn
abilities are different I mean I need to
work more to to finish this work and
like add other vulnerabilities and other
frameworks I just have a quick question
you are not surprised by the conclusion
they put it on this right even before
you started the research no I weren't
expected I was expecting what I got from
cross-site scripting I was not expecting
what I got from C surf but what I'm
saying that the last location yeah
yes wart you were not surprised it's
secured defaults matter right yeah so
okay I just I just wanted to know yeah I
was I was not I was not surprised by
that but that's the difference versus
industry and academia right in this she
was like secure your applications they
fold matter and academia come with it
it's like show me the data does it
actually work I had to prove it because
it's part of my PhD work I'm still in
the process I'm actually right now
looking at electronic locations and
trying to see what kind of tendencies
and trends can I see what kind of
vulnerability is also what trying to
look at the levels but that's my next
face thank you very much oh yeah yeah so
you know sequel injection is not a
direct JavaScript based vulnerability it
is used in conjunction along with the
framework so have you thought about
looking into lifecycle yeah like with
parameterization no queries or
developers trying to enter yeah that
kind of definitely another nobody kind
of easy enough area to look at so yeah
haven't looked at it yet but thank you
guys
enjoy life
[Music]